tonight republican senator from
louisiana john kennedy member of the
senate judiciary
committee all right senator kennedy i'm
seeing word here the democrats are
trying to defund the border patrol
they're trying to slash a billion out of
the budget there
i mean haven't they learned already what
happens when you defund the police
well jesse i'd make two points first
with good reason president biden's
border policy i think is about as
popular as a sinkhole
and that's because the american people
aren't stupid
they they may not read aristotle every
day because they don't have time but
they understand that one or two things
are going on
number one either president biden misled
the american people when he ran
and he truly does believe in open
borders or number two
the people that he has put in charge of
border security
um are not qualified to run a hot dog
stand
um they shouldn't be allowed to think
for themselves it's too dangerous
now i don't know which of those
scenarios is true but either way the
result is the same
every day thousands of people
come into the united states unfettered
and we don't have the slightest idea who
they are
number two uh the president's border
policy
and my judgment is uh further evidence
of the fact that the bible
administration i think has a blind spot
for the lives and the concerns of
ordinary americans
most ordinary americans support
immigration
but they also support border security
unlike the biden people most ordinary
americans do not believe
that vetting people at the border is
racist
most ordinary americans think it's
prudent
most ordinary americans see the border
and in my judgment
sort of like it's america's front door
most americans lock their own front door
at night
why do they do that they don't do that
because they hate
everybody on the outside they lock their
front door
at night because they they love the
people on the inside
they don't want to keep everybody at all
times
out of their home they just want to know
who's coming into their home
in any event that that in my opinion is
why we uh we do have a crisis at the
southern border it's a
it's a raging tire fire and it's not
going to get any better
as long as president biden keeps doing
what he's been doing
well i think it's even more sadistic and
political
than you even described i believe they
are breaking the border on purpose
because that is what they want they want
the open border they want to turn texas
blue they want to overwhelm
the system in order to achieve more
political power but i think you touched
on a really important point
that they do have a blind spot for
regular americans
they're totally out of touch with the
towns and the cities that are
along the border and even further back
they don't understand the pressure it
puts on the
budgets they don't understand the
crime that comes in they don't
understand the
the children that are affected in
schools the wages that are reduced the
jobs that are lost
they don't understand any of it and to
be honest with you
i honestly don't think they care senator
and that
is a very very depressing thing to say
about the president united states and i
don't even think
you can say that about the last democrat
president i think it's
much worse joe biden than it was under
barack obama i'll give you the last word
30 seconds
well you have to judge people by what
they do not what they say
and if you judge president biden by that
standard then
i think he he clearly does believe in
in open borders it's hard for me to
believe that uh
that the the people he's put in charge
are
are as incompetent as the other scenario
would indicate and i don't think the
american people
support open borders i think they
support legal immigration but
broader security and the american people
are going to make their voices heard
in the midterm elections i can guarantee
you that senator kennedy thank you so
much for coming on prime time
thank you jess